he's gonna make a toast so nice to these
three oh finally that's no good strong
the entire family oh okay
what's wrong do you not think did I hurt
you hurt your feelings
yeah right there
and then the thing is they're so much
stronger than rhaenerys strong
kids are better Fighters they're not
practicing Mr Christian Gold I know and
their dad who was a great fighter is
like
that's he wants him to be his dad so bad
so bad and I want him to be my daddy too
Damon's like did I somehow father you am
I somebody honestly honestly honestly I
that was the first thought I thought
about that David is like
Damon's like you should be my kid do you
think okay we'll get into it you guys
welcome back to New Rockstars it's the
end of the long decaying Road for
Kingman you got a hole in like every
part of his body uh but just as he
thinks he's setting up the two sides of
his family for United success a little
slip of the milk of the poppy drugged up
tongue threatens to poison that as well
you guys he goes off in the worst way
possible
that's not her
oh my God okay I think we might just see
a few more heads get lopped off before
this is all over you guys this is big
question presents talking dragons our
weekly fantasy Avatar show I'm Jessica
Clemens and with me today is Brandon
Barrett hello so happy to be here so
happy to survive the night and wake up
alive feeling good feeling great uh how
are you how are you I think honestly
what
go out for viserys he goes my love
oh wow not by himself his teeth were
black oh my God his teeth were gone
black as night and he had four holes in
his face when he's with his little new
grandkids and they're just screaming I'm
like get these kids at it shot was way
too long but long long because it's like
we want you to feel how shocking this is
to see a skeleton it was really sad to
see how sickly he was uh we thought he
was gonna die like three episodes ago
okay we got a lot to talk about but when
he walks up to the throne we need to
talk about that all right guys yeah
we're gonna do a quick recap of episode
eight the lord of the tides uh We're Not
Gonna spoil anything upcoming in this
series we got two episodes left uh we'll
talk about stuff from the book that
happens before all this we'll talk about
things that happen lately later in Game
of Thrones but no spoilers for this show
so you don't have to worry about that uh
but let's get into it we're gonna do a
recap of episode 8 the lord of the tides
uh we begin this episode in drift Mark
where rhaenice is holding down the
Driftwood Throne it's been six years
since she saw her sweet husband less
they didn't end on good terms and since
we last saw all the main group of kids
so we've gone we've jumped ahead another
six years the main group is mostly in
the 17 to 21 uh years of age range right
now except for our little baby boy
Joffrey and the new kids we'll get into
those a little bit later but there's
news that Corliss has been severely
injured while fighting in the stepsons
the triarchy's back will they ever go
away I don't think so he's got a fever
he's not looking good he's three days
away from uh uh driftmark in the case
that he doesn't survive they mend
corliss's younger brother worries about
who would take the throne in drift Mark
he thinks it should be him to keep a
Valerian in the seat uh it's clear that
he doubts lucerius valerian's lineage
raniera's kid uh I don't know why he
would doubt that he looks great uh
raynius is not going to hear any of this
she doesn't want to talk about vaman
taking over but vehman is ready to bring
his petition up to the seat of power in
King's Landing so renise is like guess
I'll have to go to to deal with this at
Dragonstone we get our first look at how
one harvests dragon eggs it's a Daemon
right there climbs into a smoky cave
near the active volcano dragonmont uh
cerax rhaenyra's dragon has laid three
eggs three eggs and also the sand of
like pull it doesn't seem that hard no I
mean you've got to climb into a volcano
that is also true you gotta worry about
Cyrax coming back and be like what you
doing
has given birth to two more boys with a
third child on the way yeah yeah three
new kids three dragon eggs hopefully
they get attached it's a lot of hats and
all that but one quick thing like
looking at dragons this was great we saw
a lot of like kind of the layout of
Dragonstone where it sits on the island
you brought up dragon mount the volcano
there how do you live at Dragonstone and
dress in all black and have all the
smoke and the dragons and be like we're
the good guys right
I mean this looks like a villain Slayer
that's what I'm gonna say that's true if
I grew up there I'd be like are we the
bad guys well they don't know then that
the the juxtaposition look friendly I
mean yeah it looks like the people that
are on the water are probably the good
people yeah yeah and they're maybe
they're like well we're on good people's
side we're just bad people okay either
way her eldest son uh jaseries Jace Jace
is studying a high Valerian and it's so
cute it's so cute it's so sweet he's
trying he's trying really hard he wants
to be good at it he wants to hold up the
Targaryen Traditions even though he
knows what's up he's trying I'm gonna be
the best Targaryen I can honestly in
contrast to
um aegon yeah yes yeah it's perfect it's
night and day uh it's clear he wants to
be king who honors the Targaryen
tradition of his forebears Damon and
rhaenyra agree that they need to also go
to King's Landing to deal with the
succession of the lord of the tides and
keep it on luceris yeah they can't let
that slip away they're like well I guess
we're going too uh so they make it to
King's Landing and it's clear that
Allison and Otto are running the show
here the red keep has gotten some
Renovations religious iconography is
everywhere including a giant
seven-pointed star in the main hallway
which is like very jarring to see
Allison's wearing her seven-pointed star
everywhere that got him all over the
place and they've taken down all the fun
erotic Dragon tapestries everywhere
except for viserys's room they let the
old man keep his porno up on the walls
uh but they're gone from everywhere else
and like uh it's very quiet in the
castle like every time we've seen that
hallway before there's people Milling
about walking around a big Court uh but
not now it's like very quiet and like
the one guy who greets them when they
shows up he's like thank God
oh my gosh this place is a nightmare all
the pornos off the walls what are we
gonna do Rainier has given a very muted
reception on her arrival despite the
fact that she's the heir to the throne
that really stuck out to me like she's
supposed to be the next one and you're
like she's showing up at the back door
almost like uh where's the band I like
later when Damon addresses it and he's
like too busy to welcome us when he's
sitting and his pregnant wife is
standing classic classic Damon uh in the
small Council under the direction of
Allison NATO uh they're having a
conversation where it's clear that
they're happy to replace Luke as the
heir to the throne and drift Mark you
know Auto and Allison they want to get
someone friendly in there who will put
the Navy on their side should a War
break out I don't know why uh except for
our good old man beesbury who is too old
and slow to keep up with this Game of
Thrones but when they start talking
about putting Luke on there he's like
what are you talking about and there's
some trees in and they're like shut up
old man yeah they said shut your mouth
thank you for your added input they were
so mean to him I'm so mean to him in
viserys's room the model of Valeria is
Dusty and covered in cobwebs and our
King is in rough shape and now we've
said this every episode of Talking
Dragon but our King is in rough shape
his body is fully decaying his clavicle
is like sticking out of his skin he's
got holes everywhere including his face
he's got a missing eye we talked about
this last week but it's insane how
during that time like bacteria and germs
somehow kind of helped you live a little
bit longer as that disgusting body yeah
there's some bacteria that's good well
it's just like because I'm like I don't
think any of us today can survive what
he's been laying in his bed being not at
by rats Rainier and Damon visit him and
both are cruelly saddened by his
appearance Damon notices that they're
keeping him drugged up on milk of the
poppy uh just keeping him in his room
not letting him a 10 quarter anything
they remind viserys of the importance of
keeping luceris as the air to drift
markets why they're here but they both
clearly feel bad about bothering viserys
in this state and Rainier of course
introduces them to her to new son yes
Allison's son aegon has been terrorizing
the staff literally after one girl is
assaulted Allison is left to pick up the
pieces
by gaslighting her and paying her off
and making her drink the Moon too this
scene was horrific but it also what are
you gonna say well my wife was worried
they showed her pouring it and it was
like very blue when they showed her
pouring their teeth my wife was like
they're gonna kill her they're going to
kill him I was genuinely that's gonna be
like dead teeth I was genuinely like oh
are is she about to kill her but also I
think you talked about that well we'll
go on we'll go on and we'll get back to
you this you guys when confronting aegon
Allison is emotionally and physically
abusive telling him you are no son of
mine I mean he's a bad dude because
that's some harsh stuff he's a bad kid
well it what is he doing I I agree with
it I this I'm also like team Allison so
I'm like I agree with Allison in this
her son has been right but like you made
this fix this that is also true that is
true and I like that line where he is
straight up like you and father have
never I'm trying so hard and you don't
notice I don't know how hard he's trying
I don't know how hard is Right amen
though so his brother Eamon has been
putting in work training and combat was
Sir Kristen Cole when he spots Jason
Luke in the yard who are clearly awed by
his prowess he greets them as nephews oh
I did love that like purposely calling
out like you're my nephews I mean in the
previous episode we kind of had that
confusion where like you know the
kingsguard are saying they're cousins
they're not cousins these are their
nephews this boy has grown up I love how
they're watching the fight and they're
like oh who's this fighter out there and
then they see the eye patch and they're
like oh well and it's also like Eamon we
saw how he was treated as a child of
course he's going to put in the extra
work after not having vegar to become
the like I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna mess
him up also it's like keeping I think
it's a no it's important to note that
she like that's his nephews every those
amen and aegon are siblings to rhaenyra
right right yeah uh vehemence has an off
the books council meeting with Otto and
Allison before the big petition I did
like this they they purposely show us
that like the marbles are not in the
holes they're still in the centerpiece
so like this is not an official council
meeting they're kind of getting their
ducks in a row like hey we need you to
show up at the petition we're going to
be on your side don't worry uh Rainier
and renise have their own little
pre-meeting at the weirwood tree and the
godswood uh uh uh when the topic of
Leonor comes up Rainier says uh
something very important here she says
quote I did not order his death nor was
I complicit in it I swear this is yet
another very syntax important statement
in the godswood this is where before she
had told Allison like uh I didn't lose
my maidenhood uh to Damon uh last night
which was all true she did lose her
maidenhood to uh sir Kristen Cole yes
but here She is again in the same
godswood kind of being very careful with
her words because she didn't order
lenor's death we know he's alive and she
wasn't complicit in it because again
he's alive but uh you know as far as
where he needs to go she's just
bullshitting her right like renise
doesn't believe it at all rhaenyra makes
an offer to marry Elena's kids to hers
yeah she likes making this move too like
I'll marry my kids to your kids uh
raynese doesn't seem to want to accept
and warns her that tomorrow the high
Towers will land their first blow so it
seems like she's leaning team Hightower
on this one or it seems like okay it
after she's like I gotta stand on my own
I was like oh maybe she genuinely is
like I'm getting messed up from both
directions no one cares about me yeah
like no one gives up She's Gotta look at
first my husband is dying my children
are dead no one is looking out for me so
I'm looking out for myself which I
respect uh Rainier checks in on viserys
again before this big uh petition
argument uh and she brings up aegon's
dream The Song of Ice and Fire and she
points out that like by naming me air
you divided the realm uh and she you
could tell that she feels the pressure
of like I need to do what's right
because I'm the only one that knows
about this besides my dad he hasn't told
anyone else uh and I've got to make sure
that my kids take the throne but I need
my dad to help me out I need him to show
up I need him to be sober you got to
come in you gotta be on my side uh it
was also important there is he calls her
during this moment uh my only child
which you got other kids
Emma meant the world to him uh yeah I
know was this his true love uh and I
think this is very important because we
see how it plays out later I was also
one wondering right here do you think
Ramirez used a secret passage to get
into his room no I think she just
bypassed everyone because I would assume
the kingsguard who's watching the room
would tell Allison like hey Rainier just
went in there I don't think they did I
don't think they care they're like this
is I don't think they well they could be
but I also think it's like that's his
daughter and also unlike sir Kristen
Cole these guys aren't all up in
everyone's business so they're like
that's the princess she can go see her
dad I don't see what the problem is I
think she took a secret passageway to
get out with all those kids and Damon
well no no when she comes in later I see
him at night oh yes no I think
absolutely I thought you meant what oh
no no no the three kids and Damon I was
like that sounds like a lot of work I
think Damon was like you need to go see
your dad again 100
secret pack absolutely 100 I agree with
you okay so it's time for the People's
Court
so Otto takes the throne in the king's
name
you know he loved that I he's just a big
boy voice up there it's hard I'm
speaking out to the audience that are
still somehow team Allison like myself
it's really hard it's really hard to
beat Team Allison when stuff like this
happens so Otto takes the throne in the
king's name Damon makes an opening
petition but before Rainer can make her
case viserys hobblestone oh my God to
everyone's surprise complete a gold mask
covering his affected face it's hideous
I mean this was like stone cold glass
breaking uh sound hits the music comes
in the doors open they give them the
whole pronouncements first of his name
lord of the handles like just hobbling
to the throne literally no one's I don't
care if he was like let me go I'd be
like we need to help him he's the king
also I was like oh they're [ __ ] guys
oh my God literally like get your ass
back baby mother so as he makes the long
walk up to the Iron Throne the crown
literally falls off his head which I
found out later was an accident it was
on accident supposed to happen it wasn't
supposed to happen and Damon helps him
in a moment of Brotherly Love and crowns
him the king so beautiful yes behind the
scenes and a little fun fact fell off by
accident and Damon Matt Smith picked it
up and put it back on I mean and they
used it because he's shoving everyone
off he's like don't help me don't help
me uh and we don't see some another
person comes up we don't see who it is
he's like yeah and he sees it's his
brother ugh beautiful that moment when
Damon did originally see him with like
in bed as that like saying he had to
bring up like the reason they were there
but he like doesn't want to he doesn't
even want to it's sad it's so sad it was
pretty horrible so viserys is pissed
that the succession is even being
petitioned remember they brought it up
before he was like if you guys bring up
my grandchildren ever again I'm gonna
cut your tongue out yeah and basically
leaves it up to rainey's to decide as
corliss's wife which should have been in
the original place like that's why she
he was like no one cares about me and
it's like you are the wife of the king
of drift Market I think this is a good
move by viserys yes because it's like
his cousin and it's like they're of the
same generation and it's like we should
be in this you know it's also on your
side here it's also we're just listening
to her we're not crowning her the only
member of we're listening to his wife
the person that would know best I think
that'll be important later yes yes
absolutely so she sides with luceris
being in the air and accepts rhaenyra's
marriage proposal in front of everyone
granddaughters go yes yes they're so
happy to marry me thank God I mean hey
hey they're pretty the other two kids
are pretty they have pretty kids we saw
when raniera was a young lady and went
around the kingdom looking for a Suitor
not a lot of great options though not a
god agreement you've been with that old
man that was that knew your great
grandma oh no oh she was beautiful I saw
Queen Allison she was gorgeous
stop so famous is rightfully pissed by
this outcome and my guy calls out
luceris into Sarah's bloodline he drops
the B word
after Damon does a little say it
uh he drops the b word and he calls
ranira a [ __ ] to boot I wasn't even
done uh but Sarah he stands up and he's
ready to use the important cats paw
dagger the Valerian steel dagger that
will one day kill the night King don't
know what he was gonna do with it cut
out that tongue sir Damon beats him to
it uh with a nice little quip he can
keep his tongue beautiful stuff uh it's
a very smooth decapitation Eamon loves
It Eamon loves what he's seen Helena is
over stimulated she kind of grabs her
head which I really like uh because it
kind of shows you know we've been
speculating Helena's yeah somewhere on
the Spectrum like this moment is like
too much for her she grabs her head
aegon's like uh or eamon's like yes yes
I love this aegon can't even look at it
he kind of just is like looking down the
whole time he's like oh I don't want to
do stuff like this I just want to go
have sex I love that Eamon was like yeah
eamon's like when I move I'm gonna save
that for later when I say I love this
scene I love the actor that plays
viserys that scene
was gorgeous that was a theater that was
a this was I mean he's been amazing
every episode but this was incredible
this was that oh my God I was like damn
this actor is getting his check he said
oh last time you don't see me
I do I do like to uh how cleanly the cut
is because they set up in the previous
episode uh that Valerian steel cut super
cleanly like the maester says that when
uh Rainier was cut and we see her scar a
couple times uh during this this episode
important moments kind of a reminder of
where her and Allison had left off yes
yes yes sorry you guys a dog came into
the into the studio and I got too
excited okay so with that business be
settled settled it actually is head gets
cut off and Otto's like get that guy's
sword and Damon's like uh don't worry
about it I'm putting my sword away oh
the only way okay dinner time great yeah
the only conclusion we get is literally
rainy's being like yeah I know death I
know death very well yeah so she thinks
either way without business being
settled it's dinner time Rainier and
Allison awkwardly wait for the king who
is smartly carried in this time yeah
because we don't see him being carried
in by that I think he wanted to walk
into the throne room he did not want to
be carried into this program room but
when it's just dinner with his fam he's
like put me in the chair please I don't
please welcome I'm gonna eat tonight
come on let's go viseris sits between
his wife and his daughter with his face
covered on the side where Allison sits I
thought that was like very important too
the mask is on the side that Allison's
on so he has to like really turn to look
at him he does so viserys begs his
family to get along for the sake of the
crown because he's clearly going to die
yeah he knows he's almost dead he's like
guys you got to put this to bed yeah uh
rhaenyra makes the first move and cheers
the queen for uh her loyalty as Queen
and wife of her father maybe she's
drinking a little uh Negroni spagliano
with Prosecco Prosecco in it oh stunning
maybe that's what she's drinking I don't
know uh she also technically apologizes
in this speech she says I apologize she
doesn't really lay out everything but
she says I apologize I think theirs were
sincere yeah I think he was trying to
make a move uh you know everyone sees
the state that viserys is in they're
like let's put this to bed Allison then
cheers raniera uh and her house and
seems uh to accept the inevitable she
says quote you will make a fine Queen
Otto hates this but she says it I think
it's a moment of like we were friends
ones yeah and I think also even if they
don't mean it I think they mean it for
tonight because they do know like their
dad bet that speech was still like
please I am dying falling apart I mean
here is where we see his face for the
first time in the show and it's it's
impactful uh Jace cheers as his uncles
uh cheers his uncles uh you know he's
like I'll be the bigger guy here aegon
inament uh aegon makes some body remarks
to Bayla in front of her newly betrothed
Jace uh which Jace does not appreciate
Helena cheers raniera and Bayla after
it's clear that no one else is going to
but she's also mundering uh a little
more perhaps prophecy she says beware
the Beast beneath the Boards
[Music]
Dinner seems to be going great the
families are united they're dancing
viserys is so happy he did it he saved
the crown in the realm uh a job well
done viserys he's like you know what I
think I'll go to bed now I feel like
garbage uh after viserys leaves the room
amend uh uh he gets laughed at by
luceris when a cooked pig is placed in
front of him a little reminder of the
pink dread uh and he's had enough and he
has a toast of his own for his nephews
he calls them quote handsome wise
and strong
these three strong boys so of course the
fight breaks out and rhaenyra sends
everyone to bed Rainier wants to take
the kids home but tells Allison she'll
fly back to visit it seems like they
might just get along after all I'm very
into this in bed later viserys is near
the end and a stupor he mutters about
aegon's dream thinking he's having the
conversation from the night before with
renera he says things like the prince
that was promised to unite the realm
against the dark it was you you must do
this she thinks this is about their son
aegon Allison son aegon and leaves the
room
and leaves the room with some new
ambition viserys is left alone to die
reaching out on calling for my love my
love
and then he dies ah what an episode
incredible stuff he dies alone reaching
out for Emma we assume yeah I assume the
wifey his first wife the one who really
loved renira's mother he always carries
her ring around too like he always has
that on him uh but what episode we got
lots to talk about this episode but
first be sure to head over to new
rockstarsmerch.com where there is still
time to grab our latest Obsession shirt
Ashton ruin inspired by the house of the
Dragon Series this limited edition shirt
will be gone faster than a person
screaming bastard in the throne room so
be sure to grab one when you can check
out all of our great merch options over
at New rockstarsmerch.com
uh so Jessica this at this the end of
this episode give us the final moments
of viserys's life with him sort of
mumbling some of the key parts of
aegon's dream The Song of Ice and Fire
to Allison It All Leads us to our big
question this week
is everything that's about to happen
viserys's fault is this all viserys's
fault uh uh you know visayas had
established with Allison his wife in a
previous episode that he was a dreamer
right they had when they're on that
Royal hunt they have that conversation
in front of the bonfire where he's like
I don't ride a dragon but I'm a dreamer
I have these dreams you know in the
first episode he had told his wife Emma
like I had a vision of our son wearing
the iron Crown like uh leading the realm
right so
is this all his fault that he's like did
he is he setting everything in motion
here if I mean he's having these dreams
and if I guess the question is like do
we believe him and I do I believe him
and I believe Helena Helena Helena yeah
I believe both of them are actual
dreamers because I mean he did see he
was like it's a sun and it was a son
though it died it is the sun nonetheless
so I do believe it but I just I don't
think it's like his fault for having
these like Visions right well should he
have like let Allison in on this song of
ice and fire before is that something he
should have told I see why he didn't and
it's because not to be horrible but she
was just married in she wasn't Emma who
started this Empire with him right and
it's not his blood daughter it's Alison
Hightower so it's like she's not even a
Targaryen she was originally a high she
was a high tower uh so it's like I think
it's like the less she knows the better
and she's literally which is true she's
literally there because the realm was
like you need a new Queen so it's like
she's not really Emma she's not really
the Queen she's just there so people
will stop she's put there by her father
too yeah and her father so all right but
for what the series knows I could see
why he wouldn't tell her yeah I well we
do know that this idea of the prince
that was promised is something that
lives on in Game of Thrones right that's
something Melisandre was always talking
about uh and she gets a dude to burn his
dog the steak because it's this concept
of a prince that was promised so is this
kind of the how is that what gets passed
down in the wrong way uh via Allison and
stuff the idea of the prince it was
promising now a lot of this is on
Allison's shoulders right she knows
better
how was she supposed to know that he
talked to Rainer already about it's not
even bad it's that you know your husband
is high on drugs you just gave him a
copy no no she just gave it to him right
before he think it works immediately
well I bet it's pretty fast-acting
the guy's been taking it for days on end
for you yeah sure that's true she knows
that he's drugged up and he's at a
stupor and he's dying right and he's
kind of mumbling this stuff he's not
really talking with her he's mumbling
things and she's like what are you what
are you what are you saying and he says
aegon now of course there's several
aegons this is aegon stream they have a
son named aegon and Ray Nera very
smartly named her first son with Damon
uh aegon and name the second one viserys
uh when you're doing this knowing about
this like Prince that was promised and
how you know she needs to set up the
realm in the right way and also to Curry
favor with her dad yeah 100. so there's
too many aegons and like Alice Alice
hearing what she wants to hear she knows
her aegon is a problem uh she knows that
like obviously he's a sexual assaulter
like he's not a good dude his morals are
bad he's a mess she's done a not great
job putting him in a position to lead
the round yeah even though she wants him
to take over so she hears what she
thinks she needs to hear and now she
could be like okay great
this is what my husband wants perfect
well I think she still has maybe some
inkling because even though he does have
that sword or that like make the dagger
it still has something embedded it's
like but she doesn't know that's there
but how do she not know he's never shown
it to her she grabbed it to stab right
but it's only when it's in the fire that
you can see oh yes oh my gosh now in
that scene where she almost stabs ranira
it's held up and there's fire in the
background but it's not like lighting up
plus I I don't think she speaks uh high
volume no that is true she wouldn't be
able to read it anyway her son's don't
uh I would assume that they've been
taught if they're Dragon Riders they
know at least enough to command a dragon
okay like when aegon when Eamonn uh
conquered uh first road vegar he was
speaking Valerian uh in order but those
are the commands he was taught I would
hope that they've been taught much like
uh joserus is trying to learn it right I
think I would think they would have
learned some high Valerian I think her
family probably knows High Valerian
better than uh adelson's because
Allison's probably like yeah and
whatever they don't really care and I
don't think like viserys was really
speaking in Hawaii he wasn't but there's
something Rainier loved doing in Damon
and Damon yeah they had their little
secret
uh but you bring up a great point the we
you know we see in that last scene too
that the dagger is in his room so it's
like Allison has control of the king and
control of this dagger uh she doesn't
know the importance of the dagger but
that's where it is and that's like
raniera's best claim if she if reniro
wants to be like hey my dad told me
about this prophecy that's very
important it's very written on this
dagger Allison could be like what dagger
I don't know what dagger you're talking
about oh right where and I assume that
at this point
a lot of the power is in Otto and
Allison's hand to let out that the king
is dead or not right they can very much
say like oh the king's still alive he's
sleeping you know they've been keeping
him in his room up into this point for
years we don't know uh so it wouldn't be
a surprise if tomorrow no one knows that
the king is dead because Allison and
Otto can keep that secret that's true
they hold a lot of power right now uh
and you know we'll discuss that in our
power rankings but like it's up to them
now but Allison knows better than this
she should know that her son should not
be the king but it's almost like a sunk
cost value yeah what else is she gonna
go where is she let's see she's put up
with so much she has done so much just
to get her dad to be like I love you
which I don't know if he's still sad I
mean he said it that one time but like
just to get her dad's approval she just
put up with so much uh and we see this
too when she's dealing with Diana right
uh the the the staff member that was
assaulted you know you can see in her
eyes like I went through this and I had
to like you know marry this guy I'd have
sex with him I did never wanted to so
you could just have to put up with this
too this is all like a result of her own
trauma and just like I've put up with so
much and I've come so far Nothing's
Gonna destroy that for me yeah and I'm
gonna set up my family for Success here
yeah I don't know so you have to make
the horrible
assaulter son yeah and like really you
know this you kind of talked about this
earlier too it points all goes back to
them to Auto and and the council forcing
viserys to choose an heir yeah because
they were afraid that Damon Targaryen
was going to take over even though Damon
never wants to be king he doesn't want
to be king he saw what he saw what
happened to his brother and killed him
it killed him he didn't ever wanted that
he just wanted to be close with his
brother he wanted to have a little bit
of power you know what I mean he just
wanted to be a part of it he wanted to
be the hand right to his brother and his
brother never gave him that so he was
like on his own uh and it's just kind of
funny that like all of these problems
are a result of them forcing viserys
yeah to pick an air and they picked an
air that he didn't like yep uh so now
here we are
all of these problems you should have
just let the man rest after his wife
died
we don't have time for that we don't
have time to that uh also where is okay
we'll get into it I was gonna say
where's Larry's you didn't see any Lara
strong in this episode yeah
I killed upstairs we saw him in the
preview for next week so he'll be coming
back but yeah we don't see him this
episode we want to thank our sponsors
for this episode mint mobile when it
comes to having a dinner with your whole
family there's always a catch you know
someone's gonna ask for a favor or bring
up old drama or some of that uh the same
is true for a wireless phone service
there's always a catch but thankfully
mint mobile is out there offering
premium Wireless starting at just 15
bucks a month and the best part Jessica
there's no catch mobile secret sauce is
that the first company to sell wireless
service online only they cut out the
cost of retail stores and pass those
sweet sweet savings directly to you many
folks here new rockstars have made the
switch to Mint mobile and they love the
quality service they get as well as
savings they get compared to their old
provider years for anyone who hates
their phone bill mint mobile offers
premium Wireless for just 15 bucks a
month mint Mobile's gives you the best
plan or mint mobile gives you the best
rate whether you're buying for one or
for a whole family all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high-speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5G Network use your own phone with any
mint Mobile plan and keep your same
phone number along with all your
existing contacts switch to Mint mobile
and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new Wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and get the plan shipped
directly to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
bigq that's mintmobile.com bigq cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com Big Q
okay Jessica I got another question for
you that's kind of been bugging me with
this episode was Ray nice always gonna
back luceris's claim as heir to the
throne or do you think that was a game
time decision sure you mean like he made
if he never if vazers never showed up
yeah and said I want your opinion right
do you think if Otto had remained up
there and their little plan with
vehemence had gone over what do you
think what do you think renice was there
to do
I think she would have clearly chosen
lucera still because we still get that
that talk that she has with vaman where
she's like my husband's not even dead
yet yes and we're having this
conversation yeah yeah and then also
this is what my husband did say and he
agreed with it and honestly if I'm
choosing sides I choose this this kid
this bastard kid over you any day
because the way you're acting already
also I think with luceris he's a child
but I also think rhaenyra wouldn't guide
him in the way of like leave the
valerians out of it you know I think
vaman though would be like you are now
out of here I'm gonna get a wife of my
own and I'm gonna be okay yeah get
raynies out there and not care about the
daughters or the grandchildren I don't
and that was like also interesting is
the fact that he was like blood blood
but he did not give up two shits about
his granddaughters no he didn't not or
his nieces his nieces his nieces he
didn't care anything about the nieces
and I wasn't about to see them take the
throne he's also very much like Carlos
we're like I don't know if a lady should
sit on it yeah yeah yeah
yeah I mean I see I see vehman's issue
right like their house is kind of
getting wiped out you know like these
these children of brainer is that bear
the Valerian name are not right like
they're strong and they're Targaryen but
it's also and that's why I'm so glad
they went to writing these for her uh
her wisdom during the whole petition
because I was like we need to remember
what Corliss said at least I do because
I loved it so much when Corliss was like
they're not going to remember blood in
history they're going to remember names
and it doesn't matter that he doesn't
look like he just wants the names I
agree I agree wholeheartedly I'm like no
one's gonna be writing down what blood
type that child was right they're going
to be like his last name was Valerian
right so yeah I mean I think that you
know Rainier has offered up her children
for marriage a couple times as like a
last-ditch effort you know we saw like
uh jacaris and Helena dancing very
sweetly and it was like that was a
proposition she made at the council
meeting once that viserys was very much
into an Allison was like well we'll
think about that but you see how happy
they could have been and that would have
been a good match I think any of her
children with anyone would be good I
think renera made a smart play because
like her saying like I'll marry my kids
to your to the girls basically just kind
of securing that like there will be some
Valero Valerian blood in there don't
worry about it it'll get it'll get fixed
out it'll come back it'll come back I
think renise is in like a really
interesting position I love that idea
you brought up of like Bayman could just
like kind of push her out it was
powerful because at the very beginning
she's like my husband's like three days
away yeah and instead of waiting for him
to come back and then going down to
King's Lane she's like no I gotta go
down there now and get this settled
almost in a way to be like I can do what
I want before my husband gets back
because she could have put herself in
position right she could have said no I
should take over the throne in my
husband's dead I think she knows and she
but she was talking to Young
um Rainer so much about like no one
wants a woman no one wants a woman it's
happened to me no one wants a woman so I
still think she believes that horrible
that and also herself of like I'm gonna
speak for Mike I'm going to speak for
coreless it's like well remember that
last time you tried to run and everyone
was like the queen that never was uh
like so I think she's also seen that
like yeah putting her children in
positions of power got them killed and
so like she doesn't necessarily want to
put her granddaughter up there to be
like that's true you should be sitting
on the throne and they just like kill
her right knees is literally like I have
no one she's like I have my
grandchildren and that is it I I that
that conversation in the godswood is
important because she's she tells Ranier
like the hightower's about to make a
move and I'm gonna enjoy it like because
she still thinks Renee killed Lane or
Adeline or celt yeah uh that's where
renice is at and then she doesn't go to
that dinner later right she's hanging
out with the silent sisters watching
Valen get stitched back together uh and
it does that whole speech about like
I've seen the stranger many times I'm
not afraid of death like I could their
whole thing is like in the religion it's
like you're not the this you know the
silent sisters like they see death so
they have to be quiet because like
they're showing something that no one
should see you know that whole concept
and so they have to they have to remain
quiet about it and like cover their
faces and all that stuff uh rhaenice
isn't having that she's like no no I've
dealt with this it's too much now she's
gonna go back to to drift Mark and she's
fully aligned with raniera now whatever
that means and she's gonna have to deal
with that but I still don't think she
trusts her at all I still think she's
she's willing to undercut them but like
she knows that aligning with uh raniera
and Damon is a good move and they have
the strong Navy they still have that
strong Navy uh if Corliss is still alive
when she gets home I don't know how I'm
sure he'll be happy to see that she kind
of she held the line she she kept up
with what he wanted yeah and that's the
thing is like I think rainey's is still
like maybe if we can't trust her fully
she loved her man
stands by Corliss and whatever and they
both stood for each other even though
sometimes I was like you bringing this
up too much that she should have been
Queen I think you just want to get the
throne either way I think she's like I'm
gonna stand with whatever my husband
says and until he's dead that's when
like right it'll change but now I mean
this kind of you know viserys giving
rhaenice the final say in the in in the
succession line right that's kind of an
important claim that Allison can bring
up later you know when when if someone
if anyone questions uh the heir to the
Iron Throne you know Allison could bring
up like hey viseris said the wife is
important in picking these things in the
husband's absence right yeah 100. so
Allison could say like well now I should
get to say I should get to have a say in
it I'm a queen right it's gonna be nice
like viserys already named renira
everyone bowed to Ramiro right they
pledged their loyalty to her like this
is an argument Allison could bring up
later that like uh but serious kind of
set present accident that wives have a
lot of say in the line of succession but
that's the thing is everyone can be like
yeah well he's dead now well they don't
know he's dead oh oh yeah
viserys is dead yet so I I don't know uh
yeah I think we're near renice's next
move here it can be very calculated uh
especially if like there's gonna be
uh one or two of Damon or Rainier's kids
hanging out in driftmark right like she
can kind of have control there she has
the Navy at her disposal also via her
family so it's the youngest one that's
getting drift marked because the oldest
one is online so this is gonna be yeah
he'll be eventually on the iron throne
in theory reminder last episode he said
he doesn't want to be king of anything
because everyone that means everyone
dies guess what everyone's dying and
guess what they're decaying from the
inside yeah they're being interrupting I
mean
the way they described with having a
cordless sounds awful too like he gets
cut and he's got a fever and he's
burning oh my God yeah oh also can you
imagine like okay you're sick you're
we're gonna get you home also it's like
a boat it's gonna take it's gonna take
three or six days uh
piece of me was like I don't I don't
trust a lot of what people are saying
oh actually that are you guys planning
on killing him and you sent the Raven
ahead of time either way
um either either way I'm suspicious of
everyone in this show
um something else sorry no it was about
the so drift Mark is being taken by
luceres because the other brother is
because is in line to be the King right
uh so you when you say two of the
children you think they would send more
than one you also think they would they
would sell like or sell they would send
like viserys and loose no no I just I
mean that luceres and his new wife uh
Reyna yeah will be in drift tomorrow
right
I know it's very confusing Jesus Christ
get our tapestry in the tapestry get the
sex tapestry up
uh one more thing I want to bring up
about Ray niece's conversation with
raniera in in the godswood she looks at
the weirwood tree right and she says all
of this she basically says like all this
doesn't matter and I think that's an
interesting thing because the weirwood
right that that was set up by like the
first man it was like an old religion
thing that the the septums like left all
these trees around when they kind of
brought in this new religion to be like
look we're not getting you can have the
old gods and you can have the new Gods
we'll we'll leave all these weirwood
trees around that's important and I
think you know renise kind of has a
moment of like all this BS doesn't
matter because time's gonna march on and
things will get settled and things will
change but like it all doesn't matter so
I think she she's just like been around
so Much Death and has lost so much I
think she's just done and she kind of
wants to set things up and walk away
that's how I feel about it I think she's
just had a lot I feel it I had a lot
here's my next question for you Jessica
was there more than just milk of the
poppy in the king's drink I didn't think
so but you you made it sound like right
now you know when when we see uh Damon
kind of sniff it and he kind of snuffs
out they're like oh they've been
drugging up the killing keeping them
drugged up I'm wondering if there's more
in there if they were slowly trying to
kill viserys I mean he's doing great job
of that on its own but if they were not
helping at all right if they're putting
stuff in there to kind of keep them sick
keep him sicker like keeping them
drugged up is fine I mean there's a
great moment uh the morning of the
petition when we see them working on
viserys's body and he tells Otto he's
like I want to have supper and the
Otto's like it's morning your grace like
just just negging my guy the hard way
he's like no not now you idiot I that
I'm trying to keep them drugged up and
stuff and it's just like they don't they
don't respect him at all they seem as
just as old people man I mean I'm
wondering if they've been kind of like
poisoning him I could see Lara's doing
this he wasn't there but maybe in the
next episode we'll see like a little not
even a flashback or maybe just like he's
talking to Allison he's like well now
that the king's gone yeah and it'd be
like no one knows the King's dead nobody
wants yeah I do yeah I know and I've
been poisoned I've been poisoning him
yeah I'm wondering if there was a little
more in that drink you know we brought
it up earlier with the moon tea when
they showed it being poured I was like
do we know if Moon teen's blue I don't
know if that's the right color like I
still don't know if that girl survived
or not you know we never saw it right
because when when they offered it when
you're a drank or when it was given to
Rainier we don't know if she drink it or
not uh we didn't see it we just saw it
just like seeing it poured out I was
like is it supposed to be blue I don't
know I'm not enough well we don't know I
don't know you're not amazing I'm not a
maester I don't know uh maybe it's just
some juice we'll see I think they've
been kind of poisoning or like keeping I
think there's more than just milk of the
poppy in there I think there was like
some stuff that was not good for him uh
another quick question for you Jessica
what is talia's motivation for visiting
the White Worm this was a little scene
we see right before the final scene uh
the White Worm of course is uh messaria
uh Damon's former lover was almost going
to be the married to him he used her as
a pawn she's now like the rumor maker
right the white one she's the one
Spanish rumors we see Talia come visit
her uh at her little house remember this
scene this happens right before we see
viserys die after dinner before viserys
it was very quick to be fair you guys I
watched this episode two days ago we
were off yesterday
uh this scene right here okay so she
comes to visit and uh Masari is like oh
a little a crazy night at the castle huh
and she was like uh-huh uh-huh okay
what's going on here okay who's on whose
side which side is Talia working for
here I think she's against the
targaryens do you so you think she's
coming of her own volition to to give
these rumors to the a white worm
massaria for money or for whatever she
does look kind of kind of like down
right she seems very demure she seems
like almost like I shouldn't be here
like I don't want to be doing this so
you think that she's there on her own
volition spreading spreading rumors I
don't know if it's on her own because
you don't think she's working with
lyrics well I keep coming back here's
the thing we know right we know Otto has
used the White Worm before to get
information from her 100. do you think
Otto sent Talia there on purpose to
spread some information
we don't know what information is being
shared that's true we don't know that I
don't think it's Otto because I feel
like he's learned his life well maybe
because viserys is more decrepit now
it's not as easy to catch a little spy
but I'm like I don't know if you do this
again if
Otto and Allison want to kind of spread
their word among the small folk that
Rainier is bad or that she's got bastard
kids or all these things they could kind
of put false stories out there or put
true stories out there into the rumor
mill and let that spread amongst the
small folks that's true because they're
important in this if like if if you know
you we renera has shown that she doesn't
care what the small folks think like
yeah she didn't when she had her crazy
night out in town she's like I don't
care what they think I'm gonna be the
queen who cares but it's like it's
important because if they rise up
against you you got a rebellion on your
hands and that's problem right you don't
want that so I think it could be that
like she's out there spreading story or
Otto is purposely feeding stories to the
White Worm it could also be you know the
White Worm says like oh Chris and I have
the castle but the White Worm could be
sharing some more information to Talia
which will make its way to Allison okay
real talk so there's several ways this
scene could go I thought it was
important you brought up you know we
didn't see Lara strong at all this
episode right uh we didn't see him at
all we also did not see Allison interact
with sir Kristen Cole at all he's been
training up he's been training up Eamon
but she's kind of keeping her distance
from him too and now she's got this new
Confidant and Talia you know when when
they're talking to Diana and that scene
and Allison is like hey you already told
me you told Talia and you told the
kingsguard and you said you can keep
your mouth shut and the girl's like
she's like so worried uh that that scene
was so insane like Allison confronting
her own sexual assault that's the part
where I was like crazy it's just crazy
very well active it's horrible because
it's like yeah she still did that but
it's like you could see the pain in her
afterwards when she's confronting aegon
about it she was like why are you doing
these things like these are horrible
things I wouldn't know I didn't make you
to do these horrible things but it's
like yeah that you don't talk to them
enough I guess I as trauma passed out to
the generations but if I I think there
could be a thing here where like Allison
is choosing the wrong confidants right
so Kristin Cole is a psycho and a bad
guy and like he's he can't let it go
Laris huge psycho huge bad guy well I
can't let it go these people and if they
didn't send Talia down there to talk to
the White Worm Talia is is a bad choice
and a confidant right is this showing
that Allison has not chosen her her
people well
I think they came to her and she doesn't
know not not necessarily how to say no
but more of like
it's like I don't have people rooting
for me I don't have any people on my
side so these people aren't I need to
play dirty you think she knows she needs
to play the thing is I don't I don't
know and this is where it's like because
I'm an Allison stand that I'm like I
don't know it's kind of hard because
it's like renair doesn't have to do
anything and she's fine she doesn't have
to do anything and she's smart because
she's the princess and because she's a
Targaryen but Allison does have to work
twice as hard as she does and so like
people that are overly like I stand with
the princess and it's like well the
princess has done wrong it's like
Allison needs to take those people that
like don't agree with the princess and
she doesn't really have that many eggs
to choose from it's like you're gonna
like cutting out people's tongues and a
guy that had sex with the princess
before so also yeah that I mean yeah
it's been six years but I was like this
is interesting so Kristin Cole is like
fine but maybe it's because he doesn't
want to mess with Damon well I think
he's he's gotta he's got a buddy in in
Eamon right he's training up payment
he's like this guy can be a fighter you
know I'm I'm on he'll be a great
addition to the greens it's going to be
great I think he's found his like Focus
there I can train this boy up and get
him in the right way it's also important
to remember you know Messiah was with
Damon early on uh and kind of she was
there the night Damon had in the world
not only the town and like kind of
crashed to her place and she's like pay
for the room on your way out right but
do you think they could still be working
together is this is she gonna is Talia
about to share some information that is
gonna help Damon or is Damon feeding
information to Messiah that is then
gonna make its way back to Otto do you
think do you think Messiah could still
be helping Damon could they still be in
Lion here or do you think they're fully
on the outs
did that last conversation they had
seemed like she really hates him because
because she was using it she's got her
new that's what I was saying she was
kind of using him even though he was
being mean to her yeah she was like I
only married you because I wanted to get
out yeah I think this scene is going to
be very important in these last two
episodes yeah I think Messiah and David
could still be working together and
they're going to feed some false
information uh but yeah it's clear that
there's leaks on all sides someone is
getting leaked here we just don't know
who we're gonna find out uh okay Jessica
one final question for you here
where's Darren where which one is Darren
okay so in the books Allison and viserys
have four children together they have
aegon they have Helena they have aemond
and then later on they have Darren in
the timeline of the books Darren's
actually born not long after josaris was
born but we haven't heard of Darren I
believe he spent some time in Old Town
in his youth so maybe he's there right
now but they didn't bring up Darren
before the death of viserys do you think
they still had Darren do you think he's
gonna show up at some point I don't
think they would cut that that would be
fun if he's a major character otherwise
I could see what if he's a bastard and
they change the storyline oh they change
the story to make him
with viserys you mean with Allison whose
bastard is Darren it would be Allison's
kid that you have with another man yeah
so she got pregnant from another man
yes kept it from viserys shipped it away
and viserys never knew and viserys
doesn't know that would be some wild
stuff I'm only assuming this because I'm
like okay what other way would we see
this character come in after viserys is
dead unless Allison is pregnant right
now and we don't know yet but it's like
it has to be it had to be a child that
got away they got it that random way
I gotta get out of here let's remember
that Allison didn't really want to have
kids uh remember that scene where she's
just holding a crying baby in the window
through the barred window like get me
out of this get me out of this hell
maybe after like the third she was like
I can't I can't maybe I don't I don't
know if they've cut this kid out
completely I don't know he's he does
play a role in in you know he does stuff
so what if it's a baby if they got rid
of him completely I'm just kind of
surprised they haven't brought him up
yet I mean they've established that
Helena and aegon have kids remember
Helena kind of comes into the room when
Allison's talking to aegon is like
where's Diana she's gonna dress the kids
and uh Allison's like don't bring with
Diana right now what if Diana's kid is
going to be the Darren if she has a kid
if she has a kid but I think it'd be
interesting if she like the moonsi
didn't work and she's like I have a kid
and it's right for it and what do we
know about Game of Thrones this happens
all the time here's this random
uh well I hope Darren shows up I'd love
to meet this kid he's got great parents
uh let's talk about our power rankings
Jessica let's wrap this thing up who
gained the most power in this episode I
mean or of House of the Dragon not who's
the most powerful who gained the most I
think I agree with you I think it's
Allison I think it's the high Towers
died and that's the thing is like in
that they hold on one millisecond there
you go
on their side they have like the city
watch the military well so when does
rhaenyra officially get to be crowned
cute Queen well it would be when viserys
is dead so technically it would be
Rainier right because it doesn't have to
go through yeah it should she is she is
the heir to the throne I'm gonna say
it's her then because it's like there's
nothing that Allison and Otto can
directly do right now it goes directly
keep anyone from finding out oh that's
true that's true okay never mind I go
back to the high Towers I go back to the
high Towers I think that's a good one
they have a lot of power right now they
hold all the cards they got a problem on
their hands but they got a lot of power
I think rainis gained the most power
this episode because she gets to keep
drift Mark to her grandchildren yeah
through her grandchildren and what
Corliss wanted she gets to keep that
she's got runira on her side now for
sure she's bonded her family into
Ramirez family by mayor agreeing to that
marriage proposal in front of everybody
no takes backsies no takes backsies no
take backs you still has control the
Navy she's got the Rainier and Damon on
her side they have dragons they got
three more eggs they got a lot of power
you know so the high Towers via their
position have a lot of height of high
power in the high tower right now but
what they don't have is the element of
surprise because now we're near can
strike back whenever she wants she did
say to Allison I'll return on Dragon
back
she was saying it in a nice way at the
time she's not gonna do it in a nice way
I think uh when word gets out about
what's going on she's going to want to
know where her dad is uh so I think uh
rhaenice gained the most power of this
episode yeah she's really set her set up
she's she's sad and she's lost a lot
she's gained a lot of power this episode
Jessica who lost the most power in this
episode of Game of Thrones does Bayman
count House of the Dragon
lost a lot of power uh
motor skills those kids
whoever was the DPN director for this
episode they said keep the shot on his
close-up blur out the finger a little
bit we know he's pointing what a
performer I said yes he did lose life oh
this is episode
it's so funny because it's like a
Valerian gained a lot of power but yeah
and also lost a lot of power
um I guess genuinely I honestly would
say
other than vaman vemon
um I I keep somehow trying to lean aegon
because it's like aegon is trying to be
in line right for the it's like it's
it's like yeah people are gonna he said
before he didn't want it at all he
didn't want it at all he didn't want it
at all but he's the firstborn and then
on top of the second
born first of Allison's whatever yeah so
it's like it's like he doesn't want it
but Allison's like you are the first one
so they're gonna look at you and then
they're gonna look at Jason renera and
Jace doesn't look like a bumbling idiot
assaulting people you are out of your
mind we're trying to spew that rhaenara
is a horrible person and instead to the
streets they're gonna hear that you're a
rapist like this is not what you're
supposed to do and so I think it's like
he's trying they're trying to set him up
so well but he keeps just punching
himself down like even in that
decapitation scene like he doesn't even
want to yeah he's like I don't like this
I don't want to deal with it I don't
want to have to do this kind of stuff
yeah it's not for me yeah he he lost a
lot of power I would almost argue that
your Sarah has lost a lot of power this
episode he gets married like he gets
Bela what a win what a win what a win
he's great he's getting all that but
like he was kind of shown you know he
gets punked at the dinner right and
Eamon looks tough and I think it doesn't
look good for our strong boys like they
don't look so tough their brains their
bronze and I'm like it's like when they
get back to Dragonstone Damon better be
like all right pick up a sword let's go
you boys need to learn how to stand up
for yourself I really I'm like Eamon
loves rhaenyra so I'm like you're gonna
stand with her kids no matter what you
better because I don't want you looking
at Eamon and being like
yeah Damon does me like man I wish you
were on our side yeah
we're great we're crazy people just lost
a little bit of power this episode it
doesn't look great as a lineup it's so
interesting it's not great he's not he's
not at least he's I think he's trying
he's trying I think his is in the books
which is great but I'm also like this is
also Game of Thrones age so books don't
really help you right now these are a
maester killing people yeah is tough
stuff well I think that's it for this
episode a big question presents talking
dragons Jessica we got two more episodes
left of this series we cannot wait uh be
sure to join us here next week we'll be
back on Monday don't worry no more
holidays left for us uh and be here for
our final two episodes of Talking
dragons and Lincoln we'll do a wrap up
after the season is over uh uh before we
head on into the darkness without any
more houses we'll invite our best friend
uh Emma Darcy yeah I'm a Darcy come on
anytime you want Olivia Cook anyone from
the show did you know the Emma Darcy is
okay sorry you guys you know how I do
this 30 years old oh yeah that person is
30 years old looking great looking
person they are amazing did you know
viserys was 57 when he died
don't forget to check out our mini great
merch options over at New
rockstarsmerch.com follow Jessica at
Lulu underscore Clements follow me at
Brennan Barrick and be sure to subscribe
to big question wherever you get your
podcast subscribe to the YouTube channel
whatever you listen to it do it thanks
for watching join us here next week and
be sure to say it drakota bastard